well we have a lady that is definitely
counting her lucky stars
what an escape
yeah i i almost couldn't believe it
thank you yeah
take us through the game because it felt
like out of the opening you were doing
fine and after that something really bad
happened because you ended up in a very
difficult position
right so i did prepare a little bit not
specifically the line that she played i
was kind of looking more at bishop takes
e5 and that is the main line right right
right so it's very interesting actually
like bishop takes um knight d7
bishop f4
uh
six perhaps yeah knight f6 now and the
idea is that now you do have knight c7
because if bishop b4 there's going to be
visual d2
so um
qd8 and then knight a8 queen e4
92 queen a8 and there's some wild stuff
yeah it's it's crazy but somehow and
most of the lines my keys okay even if
it's on v8 and i have the queen side
pawn so
it's not it's not like anything crazy
for black but it's just a game so i
thought it could be interesting
uh but she took away the pawn and i
didn't remember most most of the and by
the way but this preparation i had here
it did feel like you surprised her in
the opening with this idea of b5 and e5
right that's very rare i don't surprise
many people
but yeah so i thought i thought i played
normal and then all of a sudden my
position is just
so difficult to play
um
yeah especially here i feel like knight
d3 is probably my only move i could
consider going back to c6 but then f5
comes
and um i felt like this was just the
worst version of
something um similar to what happened in
the game
take with the knight or uh
probably
oh i have time bishop
right
is f6 still
[Music]
possible i wasn't always i was never
sure
[Music]
if those are six like she's just going
to sacrifice the exchange
it looks very scary it does it does
maybe you don't even have to take on f6
maybe you can go bishop takes b2 be even
uh
more hungry
oh
okay
kind of goes on style yeah so maybe this
was maybe this was better i felt like i
was
completely out playing the position
and i didn't know exactly
like if it was just one moment or
a combination of bad moves probably that
but it just felt like and you fell into
this very difficult position right and
let's uh speed things up a little bit
and go all the way down the biggest show
is that my pieces are on the opposite
side so nothing can help the king side
like my bishop luckily i have that
bishop e3 that just at least you know
puts it to use but
but in general my position is just so
bad however you just basically had to
wait for her to find something
right yeah i felt like i had some hope
because i i saw this whole thing so
let's stop here yeah did you see the
winning move for white
at this point no
there's a winning move there is a move
that forces the resignation
oh my goodness
no i just your your only defensive uh
piece is the rook on d6 how do you
distract that oh there's rook d7 rook
december yeah
there you go that is so beautiful i yeah
i didn't see that at all i was hoping
that i mean
my position is still worse i felt but i
was hoping that at least now i kind of
survive and we knew that you're back in
the game after this
she told me that she missed the rook d6
you only saw queen takes c6 and
obviously that doesn't work and here i
was like okay i got to survive after
queen d6 but then i was thinking a
little bit longer and i actually just
have queen of three so that was that was
a very lucky
talia a big escape for you still
congratulations
and we're looking forward to seeing the
rest of your games thank you keep
fighting keep fighting tell you wow what
a save come on coach
and i had written that one up
life insurance